Hi my name is Morey Aldeeb.
I was born in Egypt.
Worked on a farm til third grade
and then I came with my family to the USA.
And I continued working and also going
to school since we had to.
But working full time didn't
make school go well.
I was mostly sleeping,
and I wasn't doing well at all.
And that continued that same
exact way til eighth grade.
And my family was also in the middle
going back and forth between
Egypt and here and nobody had
decided yet exactly what we were doing.
But then when high school started,
two weeks in, my house burned.
And I was like, that's it for school.
There's no way it's
gonna work out anymore.
But after a year and a
half of being homeless
and in a shelter, my
family was able to move
in some where stable.
And life was getting a little stable so
I was willing to give
high school another shot
and let's see ya know, if I could really,
if school would actually work out for me.
Thank God that I found Khan Academy
and they had everything that I needed.
'Cause I needed Pre Pre
Algebra to actually start
my way and actually be able
to learn at an equal level.
So they had it all for me.
Ya know, they had Pre Algebra and then
Pre, and then they had
Algebra, and then they
had the whole path just
set up right there for you.
Where I didn't even have to organize it or
find someone to help me organize it or
figure out what I would do.
And I went down through every video and
as I learned and I learned then things
were getting easier and
the pace was what I wanted.
It motivated me a lot
that I felt like I could
actually learn.
And I was learning and getting happier.
And things were working out ya know.
And I continued that
same way and that even
drove in a love for math for me and after
finishing every video that was there,
I finished high school
and that year and a half
I graduated in 11th grade.
After finishing the 11th
grade and I went through
Queens College and I
knew I could learn math
so I continued learning
math and Khan Academy
was still there for me.
They had Calculus and
they continued through
Statistics and Probability,
and every class that I needed
to continue to get my,
to do well in math and
I was able to finish in
my Applied Math degree in
two and a half years.
And now I'm doing my
second bachelor's here at
Columbia University
after transferring here.